hey folks welcome back to reality check
Marilee since the 1970s computers have
been getting increasingly powerful and
as a result gaming has progressed
alongside enabling fantastic advances
like more complicated visual effects
bigger environments and even exciting
new ways of building entire game worlds
and today we are here the new current
gen is the age of the ps4 Xbox one Wii U
and the gaming PC but where will we be
in ten years time perhaps a new console
generation may be some sort of PC
console hybrid or maybe your PlayStation
will play you yeah I really hope that
one thing we can guarantee though is
that be it 10 20 or even 30 years down
the line
our computers will continue to get more
powerful or will they you see the future
of computer power is by no means a sure
thing right now in fact top computer
scientists from across the world are
looking at entirely new ways of building
these machines and the king of potential
that the Holy Grail is something called
quantum computing
[Music]
so the way we currently build computers
me it's always switches
we use transistors which are tiny
electronic switches in the computer and
they're more powerful we want a computer
to be the more switches the more
transistors we try and cram on a chip
problem is there's only so small you can
make these transistors before they
become the size of an atom current
estimates say that in less than 20 years
we'll be trying to get to that level and
then what happens then so we need a
whole new way of building a computer if
we're going to try and get around this
ultimately we're going to have to face a
fact we're going to have to deal with
atoms inside our computers this is the
basis of quantum computing it's a whole
new way of building a computer using
quantum mechanics now I know this sounds
pretty complicated but think of it this
way
quantum mechanics just explains the way
very very small things behave you see
when you get down to the size and scale
of atoms the laws of physics that we all
know and love from the large-scale world
that we experience every day don't
really work when you get down to the
size of atoms weird and wonderful things
can start to happen it's almost like
they can perform magic tricks and this
has huge implications for building a
computer so once we get down to the
level of switches in our computer being
the size of atoms we kind of have a
problem because atoms behave in in such
a weird way that that they kind of
misbehave if you try and use a property
of an atom for a switch so maybe if the
property is one-way your switches aren't
if it's what another weights off it
doesn't stay one or the other so we have
this inherent problem that atoms don't
don't behave like a good switch and it
would seem that this this behavior that
we call quantum mechanics is actually
gonna ruin our computer the key is to
try and embrace that weirdness and use
it to build a new kind of computer that
is is completely different from what
we're used to where the switches are
these weird quantum switches
okay so what exactly is this weirdness
we're talking about and what strange
ways can very tiny things behave well
one example is superposition so far no
one has really figured out exactly how
or why this happens but it essentially
means an atom can exist in more than one
place at once all right
how on earth I think I'll let Nikolas
have a go at explaining this one
basically suppose you take an atom which
can have different kind of properties
let's say for example we'll talk about
the color of the atom atoms are really
colored but you'll do it's just an
example and suppose you gave the atom
one of two choices the atom could move
over here and if it was there it's going
to get painted red or if it went over
here it maybe ends up yellow and suppose
because it's so small you don't really
know which one's happened it goes off
maybe it's got red maybe it's got yellow
and then you bring it back to where you
know it is and you take a look at it
what you'll actually find is that it
doesn't end up red and it doesn't end up
yellow it can end up orange which it's
kind of weird because that would
normally mean that it had to be both
colored yellow and red it needed to know
what was happening in more than one
place even though you never see it
actually being in more than one place
and this is the trick of superposition
some properties of atoms kind of behave
as though they feel like more than one
option and this it can seem like it
would be a problem for making switches
out of atoms is it on is it off is it
what's going on but it can be really
useful right so that is kind of crazy
but let's accept that superposition is a
thing how then can we go about
exploiting this to completely
revolutionize computer power and
therefore gaming as well so if you want
to build a computer that really uses
this this quantum magic weirdness then
you have to throw away the idea that
your switches are ever going to behave
and instead of using what we normally
call it a bit like a zero or want to
switch on or off we use what's called a
qubit a quantum bit and in that
situation you just accept the fact it's
going to be strange and you have to
completely rethink how you're going to
program and and build your computer so
that this is
your fundamental unit of computation
this weird behavior when you do that
things start to get amazing you know
what I think building a computer around
these new weird quantum bits sounds
really exciting currently this
technology though is still very much in
its infancy and while people have built
quantum computers they are very
primitive and contain only a few of
these quantum bits but what if we allow
ourselves to speculate say in 30 years
time we've made significant progress
with quantum computing what exactly
might this look like and also what
specifically could this mean for the
future of gaming so if you ever do see
pawns on computers like on your desktop
because they're very good at certain
specific problems you'll likely see as a
kind of special chip a quantum chip
that's surrounded by your normal
computer and and it gets cold whenever
you need to solve a certain kind of
problem and so realistically it's not
going to be that you get like a quantum
desktop it would just be as probably a
small part of it how a quantum chip
could be useful for computer gaming is
quite an interesting question because
we're still relatively speaking in very
early days trying to understand exactly
what a con a quantum computer can do but
there are some tasks it's better at that
we could imagine would be useful for
example it's very good at searching
through long lists and that is very much
the back end of a lot of programming and
of a very interesting area that's still
being understood is that it turns out if
you take too small things like atoms
that have this quantum behavior and you
interact them and then move them far
apart they maintain a kind of a link
that is much much more powerful than we
can actually explain and this is called
quantum entanglement and that's you know
it's not clear at all what kind of
benefits that could give but it's got a
love potential so what do you make of
quantum computing are you excited about
its potential in the future let me know
in the comments down below or by
tweeting at me at cam Fraser on my last
week on reality check I explored a
second batch a part 2 of PC graphics
terms and what they actually mean and
then at the end of the show I asked if
you guys wanted a part 3
and it seems that you definitely do so
that is what I'm gonna do next episode
don't say I'm not good to you see you
next week
[Music]